dazu seien herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live euren ihrem live stream zur
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen und
wir reden mal wieder natürlich über die
korona pandemie und über die
schwierigkeiten mit den impfungen die
impf lieferungen der impfstoffe läuft
immer noch nicht optimal das ganze heute
abend hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium einräumen
müssen dass bayern tag in den kommenden
zwei wochen seine liefermengen
reduzieren wird und trotzdem recht
gesundheitsminister sparen mal wieder
vor im bis ende august sollen alle
kinder ab zwölf jahren ein impf angebot
erhalten das hat er heute unter anderem
im zdf mittagsmagazin bei uns gesagt
dabei muss man feststellen
noch ist gar kein impfstoff für
minderjährige in der eu zugelassen am
freitag wird die europäische
arzneimittelagentur dass eventuell
ändern und bekanntgeben ob sie eine
impfung mit dem biontech impfstoff
community im empfiehlt oder nicht die
ständige impfkommission in deutschland
muss da ja auch noch ein wörtchen
mitreden oder kann ein wörtchen mitreden
und die impfung empfehlen oder nicht und
da heißt es von einigen mitgliedern dass
sie skeptisch sind ob sie das ganze gut
finden denn die datenlage ist vielen zu
dünnen das dienstälteste mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission ist professor
fred zepp bis vor kurzem direktor der
kinder- und jugendmedizin der uniklinik
mainz und ist heute bei mir zu gast
schönen guten abend rezept verkauf und
sie sind in der impfkommission des rki
unter anderem zuständig für die
pädiatrische immunologie und
infektiologie und die
impfstoffentwicklung von daher der
richtige gesprächspartner um heute abend
darüber zu diskutieren ob kinder
jugendliche geimpft werden sollten oder
nicht natürlich wie immer auch mit ihnen
und mit euch fragen und so in die
kommentare spalte dafür vorgesehen und
sehr gerne auch per e-mail seite
erfolgte - live at zdf.de das landet
dann bei mir und ich schaue was ich rein
nehmen kann
herr professor z das ist mal wieder viel
stoff für verwirrung wasser gerade auf
uns einprasselt teilweise noch nicht
zugelassen wann gibt es die frage der
empfehlung aus ihrer kommission dann
kommt der bus - und als minister und
sagt würde gerne angebot machen bevor
wieder tiefer eintauchen vielleicht noch
mal bei viele testprozedere gar nicht so
genau kennen
wie läuft diese zulassung eigentlich ab
also wer macht was los ist dann quasi
auch ihre rolle genau oder die rolle der
ständigen impfkommission im prinzip die
ständige impfkommission ist nicht
zuständig für zulassungen von
impfstoffen sondern eigentlich berät sie
nur über zugelassene impfstoffe ist
tatsächlich so dass wir bald zu einer
extrem dynamischen zeit leben
gewissermaßen wir sind in den letzten
monaten gefordert schon zu diskutieren
und daten zur verfügung stellt werden zu
beraten weil in dem moment in dem eine
zulassung erteilt wird erwartet ja auch
die gesundheitspolitik schon dass wir
eine klare stellungnahme haben ganz
anders als die anderen 20 jahre die ich
jetzt zurückliegende des tito gearbeitet
habe da haben wir erst mal sage ich mal
einen großen berg an daten gehabt auch
über langzeitbeobachtungen um dann zu
entscheiden
aber wie gesagt es ist eine besondere
situation wir haben einen neuen
krankheitserreger für den quasi niemand
immun war
mit anderen worten anders als bei
vielleicht der krippe wo ja immer eine
teilimmunität schon besteht weil wir
schon seit jahrzehnten uns mit
grippeviren auseinandersetzen müssen
trifft also ein neues virus sehr viele
menschen die zum teil ja gar nicht viel
kränker werden als bei der influenza
aber die schiere zahl von menschen die
erkranken kann droht natürlich dann auch
in kurzer zeit eben probleme zu erzeugen
gesundheitlich probleme vor allen dingen
natürlich bei älteren menschen und
menschen die chronische erkrankung haben
deshalb ist ein großer erfolg gewesen
dass in so kurzer zeit einen impfstoff
entwickelt werden wenn man 100 jahre
zurück gehen in die letzte große
influenza pandemie die menschen haben
gar nicht verstanden die wussten ja gar
nicht was viren sind was ich diese
grippe sagt man ja das war 1918 bis 22
und ich sag mal während sind ja erst
1935 durch die erfindung des
elektronenmikroskops erfasst worden
das heißt damals hat man eigentlich nur
gesagt dass irgendwas übertragbares
viele haben gedacht werden gucken also
bakterien aber was die menschen damals
auch verstanden haben dass eben
hygieneregeln helfen dass es das wie man
sich damals über diese pandemie
entwickelt hat wir haben den großen
vorteil gehabt dass wir gewissermaßen in
vier wochen das virus identifiziert
haben und dann durch neue technologien
über die wir sprechen werden auch sehr
schnell impfstoff in die entwicklung
gebracht haben man hat
entwicklungsprozesse die normalerweise
zehn jahre in anspruch
die hat man komprimiert zu ungefähr auf
ein jahr aber auch die
zulassungsprozesse die zu einer damals
möglicherweise normalerweise haben sie
die klinik sie schauen uns erst mal im
tiermodell an und gehen dann in der
kleine gruppe von erwachsenen um zu
schauen ist es sicher dann kommt eine
größere gruppe von erwachsenen zu
schauen funktioniert und dann kommt eine
gruppe von menschen in der größenordnung
heute von 30 bis 40 tausend teilnehmern
die hälfte bekommt eine alternative
meisten sogenannte placebo die hälfte
eine den impfstoff um dann zu prüfen in
diesem großen in diesem großen
untersuchungsgruppen funktioniert das
ist der impfstoff wirksam verhindert er
also zum beispiel infektionen oder
komplikationen von infektionen
das hat man tatsächlich auch gemacht
aber tatsächlich in dem man das
gestaffelt hat man hat also im prinzip
die nächste chance schon begonnen bevor
die erste phase zu ende war und ich
glaube auch man solche untersuchungen
sind aufwändig das ist tatsächlich
deswegen gelungen weil in der
zusammenarbeit von staaten und
pharmazeutische industrie man auch sehr
viel geld investiert hat
das heißt was man den menschen schon
sagen kann ist der ablauf die zahl der
teilnehmer in studien im
erwachsenenalter die entspricht schon
dem was man auch bei langfristigen
entwicklung hat was uns aber fehlt in
der entwicklung sind natürlich die
langzeit verläufe die sehen wir nicht
bei den erwachsenen haben wir
durchschnittlich verlaufs beobachtung
von neun monaten aus dem letzten jahr
und wenn wir daher auf kinder kommen da
ist die durchschnittliche verlaufs
beobachtung vielleicht zwei monate
dieser das ganze die daten gesammelt
wurden während dieser gestaffelten
studien die gehen ja nicht an sie
erstmal die gehen erstmal an die völlig
korrekt lage genau die gehen an die
sogenannten zulassungsbehörden in usa
ist dass diese fdlr drug administration
in deutschland oder in europa ist es die
ema und die europäische medizin agentur
und die prüft die daten und dann kann
sie aufgrund der daten eine zulassung
aussprechen sie könnte auch zum beispiel
zulassungen einschränken könnte zum
beispiel sagen
der impfstoff hat von mir ist bei
älteren menschen dann ein problem
deshalb lassen wir nur für jüngere zu
oder vice versa umgekehrt und wenn der
impfstoff zugelassen ist dann ist
erstmal verkehr gebracht das heißt wenn
er spaß sagt wenn die zulassung vorliegt
kann weder den nutzen dann ist es
grundsätzlich richtig
ein bisschen schwieriger jetzt natürlich
weil sie diesen impfstoff nicht in der
apotheke bekommen können sondern aber
wenn
die ständige impfkommission was ist dann
ihre rolle wenn quasi in eine
europäische agentur sagt wir geben das
frei für ganz europa jeder kann diesen
impfstoff jetzt quasi verspritzen der
ist sicher genau die ständige
impfkommission ist sagen wir vor etwa 20
jahren im infektionsschutzgesetz
feuerkraft 20 hinterlegt worden und die
ständige impfkommission ist eine
kommission die im prinzip empfehlungen
die im öffentlichen interesse sind
treffen soll öffentliche interesse
könnten natürlich seien ihre gesundheit
zu erhalten also ist es interesse wenn
es einen impfstoff gibt sie vor
krankheit zu schützen
ich hoffe sehr individuelles öffentliche
interesse könnte allerdings auch sein
die gesamtheit der bevölkerung zu
schützen also solchen zu verhindern
das wäre jetzt also die frage kommen
weil er heiß darauf in vilich kinder
obwohl sie gar nicht krank werden damit
erwachsene geschützt sind oder ich kann
komplikationen verhindern oder aber so
steht es auch im gesetz drin ich kann
auch impfungen auf den weg bringen um
die gesellschaftliche struktur ghani
sation zu erhalten also diskussion zum
beispiel schule wieder zugängig zu
machen
das sind 30 spektrum und ich sag mal
nicht jeder impfstoff der in der
apotheke verfügbar ist oder den sich ein
mensch helfen lassen kann denken sie mal
an reise impfstoffe oder sowas ist
unbedingt ein impfstoff den die ständige
impfkommission empfehlen muss warum
empfiehlt die ständige impfkommission
dass sie sie prüft ob es ein
gesellschaftliches bedürfnis gibt
sie prüft aber auch ob sag mal das ziel
dass man damit verfolgt ob das zu
erreichen ist ohne im prinzip die
geimpften menschen zum beispiel durch
nach durch unbekannte probleme der
impfstoffe zu gefährden das heißt wir
müssen immer quasi eine balance schaffen
zwischen den erreichbaren zielen was
kann ich erreichen durch die impfung
schützen oder ausbreitung eines
infektionserreger vermindern und ich sag
mal den möglichen nebenwirkungen deshalb
haben wir natürlich auch gerne eine gute
datenlage umfang durch eine große zahl
von geimpften personen früher
nebenwirkungen zu erkennen aber wie kann
es jetzt sein dass die europäische
arzneimittelagentur zumindest schon mal
anklingen lässt dass die wahrscheinlich
zumindest den impfstoff von biontech
freigegeben wird für kinder ab zwölf das
wird vermutet die ständige
impfkommission sich aber jetzt schon
teilweise so positioniert und sagt die
datenlage ist uns zu dünn
das tragen wir nicht mit das ist ja doch
im grunde selber wissenschaftler selbst
expertise und die einen sagen ist okay
die ansagen das nicht okay ja das kann
passieren also sag mal so das ist im
prinzip wahrscheinlich auch eine frage
welche ist aber welche kriterien man
besonders gewichtet als wir wissen dass
die amerikanische zulassungsbehörde die
fdp hat den impfstoff ja schon für
jugendliche zwischen 12 und 16 15 jahren
zugelassen und ich sag mal auch da mag
man abwägen man muss aber natürlich auch
wissen dass zum beispiel die
krankheitslast von kogit 19 in der
jugendlichen population usa nahezu zehn
mal höher ist als hier
das hat mit lebensbedingungen zu tun
eine hochrisiko und den usa bei
jugendlichen ist zum beispiel adipositas
übergewicht was erfreulicherweise der in
der deutschen bevölkerung nicht so eine
rolle spielt und im prinzip wenn sie
jetzt zum beispiel wenig
sicherheitsdaten für eine bestimmte
altersgruppe oder zeitraum haben dann
müssen sie im prinzip bewerten und sagen
das risiko der erkrankung ist so hoch
dass sich das in kauf nehme den usa hat
man das ja auch so gemacht dass man in
den ersten zulassungen sogenannte
notfall zulassung gemacht hat das ist
noch was anderes als das was wir in
deutschland oder europa haben wir haben
eine bedingte zulassung das heißt für
ein jahr und der hersteller muss
weiterhin daten liefern bei der notfall
zulassung sagt den start
ich nehme den hersteller aus der
verantwortung heraus mir ist es so
wichtig den impfstoff zu haben dass mir
egal ist was dann noch fehlt an
sicherheitsdaten mit anderen worden das
sind einfach am ende gewicht und wir das
liegt ja schon eine verunsicherung also
in der bevölkerung merke ich wenn man da
rein hab ich dann kommst du zurück ok
wieso kann das eine sagt sagt die eine
behörde ist in ordnung und die andere
sagt ja findet ihr aber nicht also dass
das wird ja auch tatsächlich nicht
gerade vertrauensbildend
ja das ist ja das kann möglicherweise
sage ich mal in der konsequenz für
wahrgenommen werden ich glaube dass die
menschen erst mal mitnehmen müssen ist
dass auch die ständige impfkommission
als kommission sich den den menschen für
diese empfehlung ausspricht verpflichtet
sieht und diese verpflichtung ist
nicht nur einfach ein impfstoff zu
empfehlen sagen wir so gut nimmt den
schneller sondern auch zu prüfen
ist es wirklich in ordnung dass man hier
immer nicht das macht ihr immer
grundsätzlich sollte sie das auch tun
aber möglicherweise sage ich mal
gewichtet sie andere kriterien wie zum
beispiel das argument wir wollen das ist
ein hilfreiches werkzeug um zb
gesellschaftliche strukturen wieder am
laufen zu halten berichtet sie anders
die stiko gewichtet erstmal das
wohlergehen des menschen für den sie
eine impfung empfehlen will am höchsten
so kommt er auf individuum und die immer
auf die gesellschaft das könnte so sein
wir sagen ich nehme also die ständige
impfkommission ist ja nicht bei den
entscheidungsprozessen der immer
anwesend aber ich gebe ihnen ein
beispiel wir haben faktisch das problem
gehabt oder haben das problem immer noch
dass zum beispiel diese vektorbasierte
impfstoffe im prinzip also zb
astrazeneca die sind zugelassen worden
von der immer und als während der stiko
das betrachtet haben in der ersten in
der ersten phase haben wir gesehen dass
im prinzip für die personengruppe über
65 jahre eine ganz ganz kleine zahl von
menschen nur in der studie drin war
die immer hat gesagt sie können uns alle
haben und wir haben gesagt da würde ich
gerne noch ein bisschen mehr wissen also
empfehlen wir es zunächst mal für die
jungen menschen da gab's auch für die
versicherung am ende gab es am während
verändern wobei es eigentlich nur zeigt
dass die die stiko bemüht ist das beste
sicherster ergebnis auf den weg zu
bringen
zwei oder drei wochen danach haben wir
dann erkennen müssen nachdem der
impfstoff 1000 oder millionenfach schon
verimpft wurde das ist in einer ganz
geringen zahl von ereignissen dazu kommt
dass die menschen thrombosen entwickeln
die im prinzip risiken darstellen weil
sie auch hin wenn betreffen können und
dann haben wir lernen müssen sagt man
nur aus der ferne das im prinzip dieser
ereignisse gewissermaßen besonders in
der jungen population ausgehen in der
zwischenzeit sind aber auch daten für
ältere geliefert worden und wir konnten
erkennen dass ältere menschen im prinzip
auch durch mit diesem impfstoff gut
geschützt sind
auf der anderen seite haben wir dann
erst erst nach dem millionenfachen
einsatz des impfstoffes erkennen können
das konnte die studie die
zulassungsstudie gar nicht zeigen dass
dort risiko für jüngere erwachsene
bestehen und das hat uns gezwungen im
prinzip nach zu
justieren mit dem ziel die sicherste
empfehlung auf den weg zu bringen und
dann haben wir ich habe weiß dass die
menschen das verbittert weil ich gesagt
hat erst die alten nicht und dann die
alten besonders und die junge nicht aber
das ist im prinzip der dynamik der
entwicklung der zeitlichen entwicklung
der erkenntnisse der datenlage dazu
geschuldet und das ist sage ich mal der
auftrag der stiko auch einige
nachzujustieren wenn neue erkenntnis es
ist ihre entscheidung noch nicht da die
entscheidung der ema ist auch noch nicht
da aber die frage ist natürlich könnte
das ganze helfen zum beispiel um die
schulen wieder zu öffnen komplett für
alle und da schauen wir uns mal an die
da gerade ist schon öffnungen sie
könnten ein schritt normalität für die
jüngeren sein
das bedeutet aber auch ein erhöhtes
infektionsrisiko gerade mit der schule
haben wir ja sehr viele kontakte und
könnte es dementsprechend auch an sehr
viele leute gerade in der familie
weitergeben also das ist halt einfach
diese ungerechtigkeit die da so ein
bisschen mit rein schwingt dass man mit
seiner angst vielleicht auch ein stück
weit alleine gelassen wird weil man eben
noch kein impfangebot bekommt für die
unter 16-jährigen ist in deutschland
bislang noch kein impfstoff zugelassen
aber es gibt hoffnung
studien von beyond eckpfeiler ergeben
100 prozent schutz vor einer kurve
erkrankung mit symptomen für jugendliche
zwischen 12 und 15
die ema will voraussichtlich am freitag
entscheiden
in den usa und kanada ist der impfstoff
für teenager bereits zugelassen und auch
der us-amerikanische hersteller moderner
zeigt sich optimistisch sein stoff
schütze 12 bis 17 jährige zuverlässig
und sei gut verträglich
kinder und jugendliche machen in
deutschland etwa 16 prozent der
bevölkerung aus eine impfung könnte das
ziel herdenimmunität also eine
immunisierung von etwa 80 prozent der
bevölkerung voranbringen aber es gibt
auch bedenken
ja also es gibt auch bedenken auch aus
den reihen der ständigen impfkommission
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe professor
zepp ich guck mal hier bei uns in die
kommentare auch da herrscht skepsis muss
ich sagen also zum beispiel eine userin
ein user namens an beschreibt wozu
kinder impfen gerade kinder vertragen
das virus doch
am besten wenn überhaupt sollen sich die
risikogruppen beziehungsweise diejenigen
die das wollen impfen lassen
miss marple schreibt einem kind kind
einen impfstoff zu verabreichen der neu
ist zudem dass kanada langzeitstudien
gibt gegen eine krankheit die für die
allermeisten kinder unproblematisch ist
ist jedenfalls nicht sinnvoll
welche bedenken haben sie denn oder ihre
kolleginnen ja ja also ich auch als
kinder- und jugendarzt und im prinzip
die zuschauer die das geschrieben
formulieren im prinzip die bedenken die
die kinder und jugend ernster haben oder
die meisten von uns oder auch sage ich
mal viele mitglieder in der ständigen
impfkommission es tatsächlich so habe
ich auch schon erfahren wir haben ja die
diese jugendliche oder junge erwachsene
gesehen in ihrem filmbeitrag die sind
natürlich unzufrieden dadurch dass sie
packt viele einschränkungen erleben und
das ist ja auch ich sag mal in der
pandemie haben die kinder und
jugendlichen eine große last tragen
müssen nicht durch die erkrankung
sondern durch die maßnahmen die wir
ihnen verordnet haben wir haben sie
gewissermaßen monat lang aus den schulen
aus gesperrt oder in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen oder das hat
mir nur noch beschränkt zugelassen und
ist mal was ganz wichtiges was irgendwie
in der politik und der
gesundheitspolitik bei den entscheidern
nicht angekommen ist
wir haben frage ich gar keine großen
probleme in den schulen gehabt das hat
zum einen damit zu tun dass kinder ganz
offensichtlich und auch schon in der
grundschule wie ist das hier in
rheinland pfalz auch in der diskussion
auch mit den landes untersuchung sandler
gesehen haben dass kinder sich
wesentlich disziplinierter an die
hygiene regeln handeln ihre masken
tragen abstand halten und dran seinen
gewissen alter zumindest ab 67 jahren
geht das schon das ist erstaunlich als
dass jetzt junge erwachsene zwischen 20
und 40 tun
die dann dort doch mal wahrscheinlich
über die stränge schlagen oder so und
das ist schon beeindruckend und wir
sehen im prinzip dass es die meisten
einträge von infektionen den schulen
aufgetreten sind sind kinder gewesen die
es außerhalb der schule durch im
öffentlichen leben also an öffentlichen
plätzen oder aber aus der familie von
der wachsenden bekommen haben während
ein kind in der schule in der regel nur
ein oder zwei weitere angesteckt hat die
meistens asymptomatisch waren erwachsene
in gemeinschaftseinrichtungen hingegen
haben mehr angesteckt mit anderen kinder
in der schule können ja auch wieder
erwachsene anstecken ja aber das findet
kaum statt
das ist so und ich sag mal das ist was
wichtig
ist es nicht nur die gute nachricht dass
kinder weniger krank werden von 90 98
prozent haben ja automatisch oder wenig
klinik schwerwiegende verläufe sondern
sie stecken ganz offensichtlich auch
nicht so intensiv an und das ist auch
plausibel denn wenn man asymptomatisch
erkrankt dann hat man eben auch noch
virus last auf den schleimhäuten
aber man liest nicht man hustet nicht
die anatomie eines kindes ist eine
völlig andere das heißt diese
verwirbelungen die der erwachsenen in
seinem großen atemwegen erzeugt und
mineiro sohn zu erzeugen die gibt es in
der form beim kinder nicht gerade heute
ist faktisch von der technischen
universität in berlin einen bericht
bekannt gegeben worden dass eben
singende kinder quasi nur halb so viel
energie sollen faktisch verwirbelung
erzeugen wie das vergleichbare singender
erwachsen weil die sind doch nur halb so
groß ja aber das entscheiden ist ja wie
intensiv ist das aerosol wenn ich dich
wenn also wenn er das nicht sagt das
sind gleich viele viren auf der über
seinen wagen
genau aber dann ist ja die ist ist die
entscheidende frage ja wie viele von
diesen tieren auf der schleimhaut poste
ich in die luft um meinen nachbarn
anzustecken trotz sind jetzt ja sorgen
dass kinder auch schwer erkranken können
das haben wir ja auch schon gesehen ich
habe hier ein kommentar von christian
jost ja sagt zum beispiel auch die
kinder brauchen sicherheit sollten zum
beginn des neuen schuljahres geimpft
sein was die stiko vielleicht übersieht
kinder haben viel mehr kontakte als
erwachsene und brauchen diese auch uns
so eine impfung soll ja auch schützen
eben damit ist keine schweren verläufe
claire und tatsächlich haben wir schon
schwere verläufe in krankenhäusern auch
gesehen
1/10 sie hatte corona hat aber nichts
davon gemerkt und ihre kleine schwester
angesteckt erst acht wochen nach der
infektion geht es beiden plötzlich
schlecht ständig wird ihnen schwarz vor
augen
erste studien aus großbritannien und
italien zeigen dass bei bis zu 15
prozent der jungen corona patienten
teils gravierende spätfolgen auftreten
dazu gehören etwa chronische erschöpfung
leistungsminderung und schmerzen in
muskeln oder gelenken viele kinder und
jugendliche kämpfen mit solchen
lankowitz symptomen
obwohl ihre corona infektion erst mal so
harmlos verlief so also auch nichts was
junge menschen brauchen können würde ich
erst mal behaupten professor zepp sie
als kinder und jugendarzt müssten doch
eigentlich auch sagen es ist besser wenn
niemand so eine longo wird erkrankung
bekommt oder selbstverständlich also sag
mal so ist es immer besser wenn wir von
einem wenn eine erkrankung oder eine
infektionserkrankung möglichst keine
komplikationen oder auch keine langfeld
folgen haben ich sag bei man muss aber
trotzdem betrachten wie groß ist
tatsächlich die krankheitslast unter
kindern und jugendlichen
also wir haben im prinzip in den 15 16
monaten in denen die pandemie läuft in
deutschland je nachdem welche welche
datengrundlage ich nehme entweder die
vom robert-koch-institut oder aber die
von der deutschen gesellschaft für
infektiologie in krankenhäusern
irgendetwas zwischen zwei und 4000
kindern behandelt während wir
gleichzeitig etwa 280.000 erwachsene
behandelt haben also sag mal so im
krankenhaus in der gesamten zeit in der
die pandemie läuft sind auf
intensivstationen 74 kinder behandelt
worden 74 im vergleich zu zehntausenden
von erwachsenen und in der gesamten zeit
in der die phantom ii läuft sind in
deutschland in assoziation mit 52
infektionen eine größenordnung von
wahrscheinlich und das aks sagt unter 20
jahren 18 menschen eben verstorbenen von
denen aber von denen aber 15 chronische
erkrankungen hatten das heißt zusätzlich
risikofaktoren aber trotzdem muss man ja
sagen 18 ist jetzt nicht nichts wird auf
die hätte man auch gut verzichten können
auch die toten perfekt auf jeden
einzelnen dann dann ist die frage ist es
tatsächlich ist das risiko einer einer
impfung wo wir als ein kleines daten
sample haben tatsächlich so viel höher
dass man auch davon ausgehen muss dass
sterben auch 15 menschen
also junge menschen die geimpft worden
sind das scheint mir jetzt als laie
erstmal so nicht plausibel zu sein weil
von also es gibt bis jetzt noch keine
datenlage die sagt dass es menschen gibt
die gegen dieser impfung verstorben sind
erwachsenen alter sehr wohl schon ja nur
im kindesalter noch nicht aber im
kindesalter haben wir quasi nur daten
von 1100 an greiss kinder die in der
studie von pfizer beim tec quasi
untersucht worden sind
da haben sie im prinzip das
nebenwirkungsrisiko gezeigt dass oder
das nebenwirkungsprofil dass man auch
bei jungen erwachsenen gesehen hat in
der zulassung zur untersuchung von
vergangenen jahr die
nachbeobachtungszeit dieser kinder ist
ungefähr zwei monate das heißt das ist
relativ wenig erinnern sie sich vor zehn
jahren haben wir die schweinegrippe
gehabt und wir haben in deutsch in
europa quasi auch das ziel gehabt zu
impfen und erst wochen nach einführung
der impfung erst nachdem millionen
menschen geimpft waren haben wir
plötzlich festgestellt dass besonders
kinder und jugendliche im prinzip
magazin entwickelt haben in einer
faktisch mehrere hundert am ende des
tages bestimmte individuen die mit einem
impfstoff quasi in der kombination wer
kommt ein problem gehabt hätten und wenn
sie jetzt auf der internetseite des
paul-ehrlich-instituts also der behörde
die für die sicherheit der impfstoffe
zuständig ist das überwachte sehen dann
sehen sie dass etwa faktisch zwei
meldungen von nebenwirkungen auf 1000
impfungen ankommen und 0 1 meldungen auf
1000 impfungen als schwere
nebenwirkungen nehmen wir also mal an
wir würden jetzt drei millionen kinder
und jugendliche impfen
dann müssen wir damit rechnen dass wir
drei 100 schwere nebenwirkungen haben
ich sag mal wir wissen dass nicht genau
und aus diesem grund geben sie so ein
bisschen auch gerade all denen ich sag
mal argumente an die hand die überhaupt
sagen also dann lasst doch überhaupt
niemanden impfen weil wir haben
überhaupt keine datenlage für
langzeitschäden ich habe hier so einen
kommentar von randi zum beispiel der
schreibt eben was war das wieder
schweinegrippe da wurde auch geimpft und
später sah man folgeschäden was sind die
folgeschäden keiner weiß was dann
trotzdem impfen impfen das ist in meinen
augen unverantwortlicher also weiter aus
das heißt bei erwachsenen anders als bei
kindern ja erwachsen erwachsene sind wir
einmal grundsätzlich noch mal anders zu
bewerten als kinder weil eine wachsende
und ich also ich bin ein älterer siehst
du deine junger mensch aber unser
organismus
es ist unser organismus ist im prinzip
aus entwickelt etwa mit dem 18
zwanzigsten lebensjahr und dann sage ich
mal haben wir eine stabile biologische
lage bis etwa 45 jahren und danach quasi
schwindet quasi oder alt hat mein
organismus und jetzt meinem alter über
60 jahre ist zum beispiel das
immunsystem wesentlich weniger fitness
ist einer der gründe warum alte menschen
auch mit 19
mehr probleme haben als die jungen
menschen das haben und insofern ist so
dass das wir da natürlich auch besonders
achtet drauf haben müssen quasi was das
angeht und wenn wir jetzt betrachten
bei den langzeitverlauf genau wie der
zuschauer angesprochen hat also die die
narkolepsie nach der pandemrix impfung
ist es natürlich so dass wir einen
solchen nebeneffekt gar nicht beurteilen
können dazu haben wir ja nur drei monate
beobachtungszeit von 1.101 drei kindern
und das besondere am kind ist ja das ist
ein sich entwickelnder organismus
insbesondere in den ersten fünf
lebensjahren aber dann nochmal den
folgenden zehn leben zu sagen entstehen
gigantische veränderungen im organismus
überlegen sie mal ein kind wird geboren
mit drei kilo körpergewicht und nach und
nach einem jahr hat das körpergewicht
gewissermaßen verdreifacht vier mal
daumen und das letzte mal vor sie müssen
das mit ihrem organismus machen oder was
das für eine ungeheure entwicklung ist
die die natur dort vorne und wir wissen
gar nicht was ein neues impfkonzept wie
zum beispiel jetzt die mr werkstoffe
oder die vector impfstoffe welche
interaktionen die dort erzeugen können
also bei den konventionellen impfstoffen
eiweiß impfstoffe tätern dass wir gucken
wir auf 30 40 50 jahre erfahrungen
zurück aber hier haben wir ein völlig
neues impfstoff soll ich was einem
wachstum der kinder vor allem an alija
wachstum und der differenzierung der
entwicklung also ich sag mal organe
funktionieren anders bestimmten rezeptor
strukturen werden ausgebildet wenn sie
menschen fragen sich immer warum ist die
pubertät so schwierig warum weil die
verschaltungen im gehirn sich noch mal
verändert das sind alles sage ich mal
kritische lebensweisen ins team viele
dinge passieren und wir wissen nicht was
zum beispiel ein informations reiz in
dieser lebensphase erzeugen könne heisst
nicht dass wir gegen die impfung sind
aber wir sagen die menschen müssen
verstehen wenn wir jetzt sage ich mal in
euphorie vorschnell vorschreiben dann
gehen wir natürlich risiken ein
eine gesellschaft kann das für sich
entscheiden oder eine
gesundheitspolitikern das für sich
entscheiden ein gremium das die
verantwortung hat sorge für die menschen
zu tragen den sie etwas empfehlen muss
betrachtet die vorteile der impfung
betrachtet aber auch mögliche
nebeneffekte oder auch betrachtet den
den anteil an informationen der uns noch
fehlt eigentlich um das solide oder eine
belastbare entscheidung zu treffen und
dann dann worden
man muss sagen mal kinder und
jugendliche sind keine kleinen
erwachsenen sondern sie sind faktisch
dadurch von das besonders belastet dass
im verlauf der entwicklung natürlich
langfristige effekte entstehen könnten
die ich beim erwachsenen nicht sehe ich
würde sagen beim erwachsenen jahr
wahrscheinlich kann ich die meisten
leben einer impfung innerhalb der
nächsten 3-4 monate nach der impfung war
mehr oder weniger gut kontrollieren beim
kind kann ich effekt auf die
differenzierung auf die entwicklung aber
vielleicht erst nach jahren entscheiden
jetzt geht es trotzdem viele menschen
die weil die politiker doch relativ
voran prescht und eben der
gesundheitsminister schon angesagt hier
machen jemand angebot befürchten dass
das irgendwann auf eine impfpflicht
hinausläuft ersparen sagt immer wieder
eine impfpflicht wird es nicht geben
das ganze ist auch aus sicht des
deutschen ethikrates schwierig ein
mitglied hat sich auch ganz vehement
oder ganz klar schon nichts dagegen
ausgesprochen aber zumindest gesagt wo
die schwierigkeiten liegen die hürden
für eine impfpflicht sind aber sehr hoch
weil es sich um einen eingriff in die
körperliche unversehrtheit handelt
erstens muss das mit einer impfung
verbundene risiko zumutbar bleiben die
nebenwirkungen müssen bekannt und
akzeptabel seien
zweitens muss die impfung auch
erforderlich seien eine moralische
impfpflicht für alle gibt es ohnehin ja
wenn ich hier in die kommentare gucke
dann gibt es hier ganz klare stimmung
dagegen also zum beispiel auch von einer
sauerei kindern den zugriff zur bildung
nur zu ermöglichen wenn sie geimpft sind
was passiert wenn die eltern das
untersagen werden sie dann vom staat
entmündigt also da muss man ganz klar
noch mal sagen diese impfpflicht ist
nicht vorgesehen dass er hat die politik
auch immer wieder betont aber es gibt
viel skepsis zum beispiel hier auch dann
von wave ist nur eine frage der zeit
wird geschrieben aber die im
die wird kommen vor hier vorher hieß es
auch dass es freiwillig sein sollte und
was haben wir jetzt geimpfte haben mehr
privilegien als ungeimpfte das sind zwar
kleinigkeiten aber dennoch sollte sowas
in einem freien staat nicht sein
herr professor selbst als kinder und
jugendmediziner was würden sie dazu
sagen wir haben eine impfpflicht für
bestimmte krankheiten ja schon bekommt
man zum beispiel erst letztes jahr sehen
sie das vielleicht auch irgendwann für
so ein corona impfstoff gerade wenn wir
feststellen wir erreichen die herren e
mobilität vielleicht doch nicht
also ich persönlich würde ich keine
impfpflicht erwarten ich glaube nicht
dass die politik diesen weg gehen wird
persönlich will ich auch sagen dass auch
viele stimmen in der ständigen
impfkommission nicht dicht sagt mal
positiv gegenüber einer maß an in
pflicht gewesen sind weil wir auch also
gesagt mal wir leben einer aufgeklärten
gesellschaft und ich denke der weg
dorthin ist dass wir menschen überzeugen
mit guten argumenten zu guten argumenten
brauchen wir natürlich auch gute daten
die wir haben und zur der kommunikation
über impfungen gehört auch zum beispiel
wie wir es jetzt diskutiert haben den
menschen zu vermitteln was wir nicht
wissen
gehen wir also eine empfehlung für
jugendliche dann müssen einfach sagen da
gibt es kenntnis lücken und wir gehen
ein risiko ein wenn jetzt eine
erkrankung so bedrohlich ist dann geht
eine gesellschaft vielleicht ein solches
risiko ein aber ich würde das nicht zu
erwarten weil im prinzip zwei
infektionen eben im kindes und
jugendalter keine schweren verläufen
machen und dann kommen wir schon eine
stufe 2 der ethiker gesagt hat die frage
ist also ist es eine moralische
verantwortung
kinder kinder zu impfen darüber trotzdem
ich sehe zum beispiel hier einen ein
kommentator knuppertz mal einblenden
johannes sommer ist schüler und schreibt
ich würde mich sehr über ein angebot
freuen da ich dann mehr freiheiten habe
und die schule auch vielleicht wieder
etwas normaler werden kann also in der
klare anspielung darauf dass geimpfte
menschen jetzt vor allem ältere sich
wieder treffen können in größeren zahlen
also quasi im grunde das kaffeekränzchen
für die senioren ist wieder möglich aber
mit zehn freunden zusammen abhängen geht
eigentlich immer noch nicht also da gibt
es halt doch ein klares bedürfnis dann
auch gerade weil wir diese
ungleichgewichte
derzeit haben ja das in der tat so aber
dieses bedürfnis hier steht entsteht ja
daraus dass man sagt ich bin in meiner
persönlichen freiheitsgraden
eingeschränkt und die würde ich gerne
wieder erlangen und sie haben schon
recht in der diskussion in dem wir uns
jetzt befinden
also ich erinnere mich zurück im januar
hat keiner gesagt nein
weg gegeben habe ich damals tatsächlich
auch so gefühlt auf der anderen seite
kann ich die argumente auch verstehen
dass man sagt man hat den menschen quasi
ihre grundrechte nicht genommen man hat
sie eingeschränkt und in dem moment wenn
der grund für die einschränkung wegfällt
dann darf ich sie ihnen nicht
vorenthalten
das ist wahrscheinlich so und es hilft
natürlich schon auch dass die
gesellschaft eben handel oder auch
produktionsbetriebe wieder in bewegung
kommen also insofern gehen wir
wahrscheinlich jetzt in den nächsten
monaten durch eine kritische phase bis
alle oder alle die wollen ein
impfangebot gehabt haben das ist eben
geimpfte gibt und nicht ich kann diese
position eines jungen menschen war ja
auch in dem ein spieler den sie gehabt
haben so ein bisschen angeklungen die
kann ich inhaltlich nachvollziehen aber
was was die jungen menschen eben an der
stelle nicht getan haben sich damit
auseinandergesetzt was bedeutet wenn das
was jetzt werde man man sieht jetzt zwar
in der euphorie den impfstoff als im
prinzip den schlüssel zur freiheit an
das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch und ich
bin auch innerlich der hoffnung dass im
prinzip dieser impfstoff von den meisten
den meisten auch jugendlichen die
geimpft werden gut vertragen wird
aber man muss einfach sagen wenn ich nur
tausend individuen in dieser
altersgruppe habe die den impfstoff
bekommen haben etwas mehr als 1000 dann
kann ich ein risiko auch quasi nur
einmal 1000 abschätzen und überlegen sie
mal die thrombosen treten auf einmal
unter 100.000 wir diskutieren gerade in
israel über die frage ob es zu
herzmuskelentzündungen kommen kann
auch in der größenordnung von einmal
unter 200.000 wie soll sich so in so
einem sample gar nicht erfassen dann
haben wir nicht erfassen und kann dann
erst erfassen wenn man eben längere nach
beobachtung hat oder eben größere
populationen in studien untersucht hat
und darum geht es einfach ich kann also
ich sagen für das was die
zulassungsbehörde erstmal prüft ist der
impfstoff wirksam das kann ich mit 1000
1000 teilnehmern einer studie machen
weil ich kann die antikörper messen die
wiederum vergleiche die mit den
erwachsenen sagt wieso das stimmt aber
die risiken können wir nicht abschätzen
und ja es ist eine komplexe
entscheidungen die die auch wir die uns
bewegt ist es so dass wir dann jetzt
schnell in eine allgemeine impfung uns
bewegen müssen oder ist es nicht klüger
zu sagen zunächst müssen wir wie am
anfang bei der priorisierung die am
meisten gefährdeten also die chronisch
kranken um ihnen einen schutz cocoon zu
geben und betrachten dann mit ruhe was
wir an zu
und setzt den erkenntnissen bekommen um
dann gegebenenfalls ist für die jugend
jugend in poprad teilnehmer in unserer
gesellschaft zu empfehlen eine idee wie
dumm kann natürlich für sich entscheiden
in dem moment wenn die immer das zuletzt
ja das könnte freitags könnte was könnte
freigekommen und wenn die politik sagt
wir wollen das aber also sagen wir die
ständige impfkommission gibt eine
empfehlung die ständige impfkommission
erzählt nicht darunter
die ständige impfkommission wird nicht
den daumen runter machen sondern die
wird sagen im prinzip der impfstoffe
zugelassen man kann ihn also ich sag mal
ich kann nicht sagen was die ständige
impfkommission entscheiden oder
empfehlen wird wenn sie erst nächste
woche berät und wenn aber seine
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
kommt dann wird professor mertens unser
vorsitzender das sagen und nicht alle
stieg um mitglieder als tun
also ich geben jetzt meine eigene
position wieder und insofern kann man
sagen wenn der impfstoff zugelassen ist
dann ist er erstmal verfügbar
wie immer kann im prinzip in ihrer
bewertung andere schwere karte setzen
oder andere gewichte setzen als wir das
tun bei uns geht es um auch die
sicherheit so gut wie möglich sie
darzustellen ist und es könnte natürlich
sein wenn das jetzt praktisch politisch
zuvor getragen wird dass man auch sagt
gut
wir sehen ein besonders hohes bedürfnis
bei gefährdeten kindern und jugendlichen
weil sie das chronische erkrankungen der
lunge des stoffwechsels ein höheres
risiko haben sodass ich unterhalten
unwissenheit auf der seite der
sicherheit in kauf nehme aber wir sehen
nur eine ganz kleine population von
kindern die wir auch da gesehen haben
mit teams mit entzündung symptomen oder
langfristigen verläufen ist gerade
gestern eine publikation im lancet
erschienen die gar nicht gezeigt hat in
england das die kinder mit diesen
problemen im prinzip nach sechs monaten
eigentlich gute stabilisierung schon
wieder erreicht haben und das prinzip
deshalb auch das wesentliche symptom
noch ermüdung war aber die anderen im
prinzip waren verschwunden wenn die
politik hat herr spahn heute nochmal
gesagt wiederholt möchte ein impfangebot
machen allen menschen ab 12 spätestens
bis ende august das hat er heute unter
anderem im zdf mittagsmagazin
angekündigt es geht ja nicht erst mal
darum ob ich ein angebot ob wir ein
angebot möglich machen die konkrete
empfehlung ist dann eine der ständigen
impfkommission oder eben auch im
gespräch der eltern oder jugendlichen
wenn sie für sich selbst entscheiden
der kinder unter ärztinnen und ärzte
miteinander das ist doch das
entscheidende wir bekommen sehr viele
briefe sehr sehr viele anrufe im
bundesministerium für gesundheit von
eltern auch von jugendlichen die sich
wünschen
geimpft werden zu können ein angebot zu
bekommen wenn es diesen zugelassenen
impfstoff gibt und wenn es die zulassung
gibt dann finde ich sollten sie auch die
möglichkeit dazu erhalten und dann eben
für sich individuell entscheiden können
ob geben wird oder nicht aber es wird
definitiv keine verpflichtung zur
impfung geben und dann kann jeder wie
gesagt im lichte von empfehlung die
entscheidung für sich treffen der
trotzdem gibt es hier schon bei uns
kommentare zum beispiel hier habe ich
gerade gesehen
von nina können wir gleich mal gerade
nochmal zeigen bei mir auf dem rechner
die schreibt es hört sich ja toll an
jedem ein angebot machen aber keine
pflicht aber dann müssen sich die kinder
halt ständig testen lassen das ist ja
überhaupt kein druck
also auch da skepsis was das angeht und
zu denen müssen wir feststellen habe ich
am anfang gesagt bei ontrack hat heute
abend angekündigt oder besser gesagt hat
gesundheitsministerium mal eingeräumt
dass bei uns nicht so liefern können
wird die nächsten zwei wochen die sie es
vorgehabt haben das gt impfstoff jetzt
wird noch mehr impfstoff teilweise
können in dem trio großen drei in
manchen bundesländern noch gar keine
termine vergeben werden ist das jetzt
der richtige zeitpunkt über so ein
angebot zu sprechen
und das ist natürlich eine schwierige
frage ich kann mir vorstellen dass
politiker natürlich auch noch andere
kriterien in ihre überlegungen oder
ankündigungen einziehen als wir als
mediziner oder als wissenschaftler das
tun
ich will nur so sagen auch das ist
wieder eine besondere situation weil im
prinzip der impfstoff zwar verfügbar ist
aber er ist nicht frei verfügbar sie
sagen das richtig sie müssen sich in
einem impfzentrum anmelden oder über
eine über eine arztpraxis an den
impfstoff kommen sie können also nicht
mit einem rezepte die in die praxis
gehen und da sagt unser
gesundheitsminister will ein angebot
darstellen das kann sein weil ich sag
mal ich vermute dass das die behörden
dort bessere kenntnis haben über die
verfügbarkeit von impfstoffen
aber wie sie angedeutet haben impfstoffe
sind biologische produkte ist was
anderes als ein chemisches produkt wie
aspirin herstellen
das kann ich wenn die produktionswege
stimmen immer gleicher qualität bei den
impfstoffen muss man ja im prinzip die
rna erzeugen oder
muss die die virus vektoren erzeugen das
sind biologische prozesse bei denen es
immer wieder probleme geben kann und
dann kommt es wieder zu einem
produktionsausfall oder verzögerung und
dann stimmt die ganze planung nicht wenn
wir zwei jahre von heute sind ist das
kein problem weil dann sind die meisten
menschen ich hoffe dass 80 prozent
geimpft oder 90 prozent
und dann wird ein solcher ausfall sich
nicht so bemerkbar machen heute ist es
natürlich so dass ein großer teil noch
auf die impfung wartet wir haben jetzt
vielleicht 30 oder 35 prozent der
bevölkerung der erwachsenen bevölkerung
geimpft
ich vermute 40% sich mittlerweile ja und
ich vermute 70 prozent würden gern den
impfstoff haben das heißt die wollen ja
nehmen und dann wollen wir auch noch die
junge mit reinnehmen und herr spahn hat
ja auch angekündigt dass die impfstoff
priorisierungen wie die stiko sie mal
vorgesehen hat in den ersten in der
ersten juni woche aufgehoben wird das
heißt im prinzip jeder solle einen mehr
oder weniger wochen mehr druck auf das
baut noch mehr druck auf ist nicht ohne
risiko seiner ankündigung zu machen weil
es eben faktisch unabwägbarkeiten gibt
zum beispiel der versorgung mit
impfstoffen und wir kamen ja auch nicht
jetzt freizügig alle impfstoffe die alle
vier impfstoffe die hier zugelassen sind
zum anbieten sondern im augenblick nur
ein vielleicht kommt dann der andere aus
usa auch noch mit einer zulassung für
jugendliche hinterher
also insofern bin ich sagen ja das weckt
erwartungen und wie wir bei den
kommentaren hören gibt es ja auch
jugendliche sagen das ist mir so wichtig
um freiheit wieder züge wenn ich habe
gerade noch mal ein kommentar aus
gesucht also max lorenz und schreibt was
ist denn die konsequenz kinder nicht zu
impfen das enorm hohe instanzen in
dieser umkämpften altersklasse in kauf
genommen werden ich persönlich kann auf
longo wird gerne verzichten das haben
sie gerade schon gesagt das ist nicht so
häufig bei kindern und jugendlichen
trotzdem
mir scheint es so dass hier die
gemengelagen den kommentaren vor allem
so aussieht eltern möchten ihre kinder
eher nicht impfen aber junge leute sagen
er doch herr damit damit ich wieder mein
leben leben kann auch nachvollziehbar
auch nachvollziehbar wahrscheinlich ist
es so dass wir nochmal uns anstrengen
müssen auf diesen jungen erwachsenen zu
erklären welche unsicher halten sie
damit eingehen und also ich würde sagen
bis in die 80er jahre hat man in
deutschland die pocken geimpft war sogar
eine impfpflicht brocken zu der zeit
warum weil pocken im prinzip einer
infektionskrankheit war bei der
tatsächlich in einer epidemie bis zu 30
prozent der menschen gestorben sind das
war ein
hatte bedrohung und was den menschen
heute gar nicht klar ist weil sie gar
nicht mehr von gm von sind an der
pockenimpfung sind gestorben weil er so
nebenwirkungsreichen war das hat eine
gesellschaft vor 50 jahren akzeptiert
weil sie gesagt hat die krankheit ist so
schwerwiegend
die frage ist wo befinden wir uns 2021
haben wir eine erkrankung die so
schwerwiegend ist dass wir sagen wir
nehmen unbekannte risiken in kauf
und ich glaube das muss man auch jungen
erwachsenen noch mal klar machen es geht
nicht nur um wiedergewinnung von
freiheitsgraden die man sowieso dann
irgendwann in drei oder sechs monaten
bekommen wird sondern ist an der zeit
für die jungen menschen für junge
menschen das verstehe ich nein ich sage
mal aus unserer persönlichen anschauung
hätte man im prinzip in den schulen
schon viel größer mehr freiheiten
erzeugen müssen wir hätten die kinder
nicht nicht monatelang wegsperren müssen
weil wir sehen dass es in diesem setting
weil die meisten us unternehmen
natürlich an infektionsgeschehen teilen
aber sie werden nicht krank sondern sie
erwerben eine immunität ohne krank zu
werden und wir wissen zum beispiel dass
in der freien natur wenn man nicht ganz
nah zusammen kommt man kaum übertragen
kann das heißt wir hätten die
sportvereine wieder arbeiten lassen
dürfen und und weil ich sag mal da kann
nichts passieren
das sind aber entscheidungen die quasi
auch in der unsicherheit was passiert in
einer pandemie das ist ja nichts für das
es eine blaupause in diesem oder einem
anderen land der welt gegeben hat
sondern ich glaube die erkenntnisse
haben sich auch erst über die monate
entwickelt und dann ist die frage wenn
wir zurückblicken werden dann bitten wir
sagen vielleicht sind wir dazu hart
vorgegangen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir sehr zügig
nach den ferien in den normalen
schulbetrieb übergehen können wir werden
für gehende maßnahmen weiter betreiben
das müssen wir auch tun wenn wir impfen
weil geimpfte können auch nochmal
infektionen bekommen
aber mit diesen maßnahmen haben wir in
den vergangenen monaten im wechsel
unterricht wir können aber in vorwärts
gehen glaube ich sehr gut kontrolliert
das ist erstmal super plus das die
jungen menschen das so konsequent und so
gut erzeugt haben besser eben als die
jungen erwachsenen die mit diesen
hygienemaßnahmen eben nicht so
konsequent umgehen und ein ich weiß
jetzt nicht ein junger erwachsener 16
jahre der sagt ich will das aber jetzt
für mich haben oder 14 jahre und
bespricht dass es in bezug auf impfungen
schon aus unserer sicht hat eine gewisse
mündigkeit das mit zu entscheiden
der wird diesen weg auch gehen können
wenn der falls der impfstoff zugelassen
wird
aber ich sag mal wenn die stiko
das einfach empfiehlt als ein gremium
dann wird das ja auch in der bevölkerung
als eine unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung
wagen und ist was heißt nicht wollen
sich auch nicht nehmen sondern es ist
eine frage der verantwortung die wir
unseren kindern gegenüber spüren nicht
nicht also wenn man diese arbeit macht
geht nicht darum was ich gerne etwas
immer es geht auch nicht darum was ich
mir wünsche ist sondern was was sag mal
die bestmögliche entscheidung für kinder
ist die bestmögliche förderung vergehen
da ist natürlich jeden krankheitsfall
der schwerwiegend ist zu verhindern
aber gleichzeitig sicher zu sein dass
die maßnahme die ich dazu ergreifen
nicht mehr krankheitsfälle erzeugt als
das was ich verhindere gut und das
können wir noch nicht wissen dafür ist
die datenlage noch nicht ausreichend ich
danke ihnen für ihre expertise und für
die beantwortung unserer fragen wir
werden vielleicht in einem jahr wissen
ob die entscheidung richtig war oder
nicht dann haben wir auf jeden fall mehr
gelernt aber es ist eine dynamik haben
sie gerade schon gesagt wo sich viele
mal ändert und deswegen auch viel
verwirrung herrscht deswegen sehr
wichtig dass wir darüber sprechen
der professor vielen dank für ihre zeit
vielen dank für eure kommentare und für
eure fragen heute abend wir sind
weiterhin für euch da ist jedoch diese
woche noch ein paar mal ums impfen gehen
morgen ist der impf gipfel übermorgen
eben die entscheidung der ema ob der
biontech impfstoff für menschen ab 12 in
europa zugelassen wird in der ebene
zugelassen wird auch da werden wir
weiter für euch berichten für heute
meine sack zu und sage vielen dank
ristow nächsten mal
und tschüss